I wonder if these two things really disappear
.
[Music]
Well, I can't help it. It
seemed like a long dormitory life, and it was so quick. I
've been together for a long time.
Fumio's
move into the dormitory I was surprised at first I took 3 months to move into the dormitory, but during that time Fumio let me stay at a house
.  Yone-
I'm playing a lot-Yukihira has been incorporated from the back of my head-I'm gonna catch the top, so I'm gonna do it
[Applause]
yeah I
miss everything.
I wondered what would happen when I got
rid of it. I don't know what to do with the music. Summer vacation Autumn selection is a great mutual aid. Imoni-kai
I did my best.
But there were a lot of things,
no matter how much I talked about it, I couldn't talk enough
gray.